aujourd'hui 18 juin et bon anniversaire
à paul mccartney qui a 51 ans
aujourd'hui
l'occasion de vous signaler au cas où
cela vous aurait échappé que johnny
hallyday vient de fêter son demi siècle
pour célébrer cet événement comme il
convient l'idole des jeunes donne ce
soir samedi et dimanche au parc des
princes à paris trois méga concert de
trois heures claude son père un star à
50 ans et elle entend bien les fêter
pour un anniversaire version johnny
hallyday pas de gâteau des harley
davidson
une réplique d'un pont new yorkais et
des bagarres l'anniversaire sera célébré
en famille sylvie david et bien
évidemment les copains de toujours
engagement sérieux
une scène de 120 mètres 71 musiciens et
200 sources de lumière
on
trois heures de concert 50 ans cela
donnera ce soir cinquante chansons